i'm open to whoever wins at this point
at this point i'm really open to it
at the same time i feel like i got
pretty solid reasons as to why
what's going on reject nation i'm greg i
am john so now that the godzilla versus
kong trailer has come out i thought it
was only appropriate that we take the
time
to talk about who we think will win adam
winger the director
of this movie did state that there will
be a definitive
clear winner in this film we want to
throw our hat in the ring to talk about
who we think
has a good shot at actually winning this
but before we go into that a couple of
things
first things first the poll ah i put out
a poll on twitter and i put out a poll
on our community page on youtube
asking you guys who we think will win
between godzilla versus kong the answer
is not surprising yeah
dude i realized this from comments uh
from like
the before the official trip came out
the other stuff we were covering before
the twitter poll which has 581 votes so
not a whole lot
uh you follow me on twitter so we can
get more votes 54
kong 46 godzilla john tell us what it
says on the community page oh goodness
out of 43
000 votes thank you all for joining in
godzilla
loses 45 to kong's 55 percent those are
almost identical
yeah man the the majority are very much
in favor of kong winning this there's
probably a variety of reasons why people
would
would vote for kong i mean some people
might vote for a congo you know
originally i was going for godzilla but
then i saw the trailer and it looks like
they're gonna let kong and win
some people just are like no i'm team
kong all the way there's reasons why
people would vote for kong over godzilla
totally respect that a-okay fascinating
to see that 43 000 votes is pretty
apparent all right guys but let's start
talking about who we think will win
and why why we think this person will
win
but in order to talk about that first we
will get to our definitive answer in a
second we have to talk about
the original king kong versus godzilla
movie from many many decades ago because
that greatly influences i believe the
outcome
of what we will get in godzilla versus
kong journey back to a time
i think in the 60s it was 1962.
that's right toho gets the rights to
king kong from rko for
two whole appearances in which he is not
like any of the other appearances
exactly at the time though we have to
remember godzilla
was yet to become what is known as like
an anti-hero of sorts when he started
getting like a whole bunch of films and
the rogues gallery of godzilla got
introduced
at the time of the first king kong
versus godzilla movie godzilla was
viewed as a
villainous perspective and kong was
beloved in japan
actually and he was viewed more as i
don't want to say exactly anti-hero but
a little more of like
misunderstood you know sympathetic gear
yourself to him you feel
bad for him and you want his love with
the tiny human lady to work out
exactly you know he like looked after a
human lady he had a he had a soul and a
heart
it was a very different portrayal than
godzilla so in the eyes of pairing these
two
up godzilla was taking on the villainous
perspective now the thing with that
movie the winner was
king kong however it was met with a lot
of backlash
it didn't even matter if you were king
kong from the beginning of that film
it's not just
godzilla stands what the hell godzilla
it's because of how kong won that was
the real
big upsetting factor to it now a lot of
people were like it was an ambiguous
ending we don't know for sure who won
theories going around but the
the owners of the movie the creators
toho they released a statement
saying kong was the definitive winner of
that movie they made it apparently clear
now how did he win jon roll that footage
while i'm talking about it oh boy
so kong was losing thunderstorm randomly
occurs
kong randomly gets electrical powers
defeats
godzilla like underwater off screen
right yes
he comes back out and we're left to
assume that he won
it felt abrupt it felt sudden this
ability of electrical charges was never
foreshadowed fans were not happy with
the way
of how it occurred yes people who were
like all about godzilla
did not like it but people were not
happy with the manner and how
kong actually ended up winning after
that you know eventually godzilla starts
to become an anti-hero so if you look at
where godzilla is at
now in japan he's immensely more popular
than khan
at the time you know he was a little bit
more favored but with the way godzilla's
image has changed over time and
with the franchise you guys know the
legacy of godzilla godzilla's a lot more
beloved now
so now we get to this movie godzilla
versus kong the trailer comes out and
i'm a little bit surprised during the
reaction i i did look at you i'm like oh
they're making god's allowed to be the
villain this is kind of surprising
definitively so it seems yeah now just
to make it clear we know there's the
theories going around about mecha
godzilla
actually wearing a godzilla skin suit
kong is actually fighting
mecca godzilla he just thinks he's
fighting the real godzilla
we absolutely believe mechagodzilla will
be in this movie it seems likely that
godzilla and kong will team up at one
point to take down
mechagodzilla however i think the
filmmakers know
that it would be a complete cop-out if
there was not at least
one real fight between the real godzilla
and the real kong
so when it goes to answering this
question we're talking about
that fight we're not going off of the
theory that kong is actually fighting
mechagodzilla we're going off of the
hope
that the real godzilla and that the real
kong will be fighting each other at some
point in this movie this
is where our answer is coming down to
it's interesting looking at the trailer
because they're picking up godzilla as a
villain in here which is
kind of the antithesis to what the last
two godzilla movies were where he was
more portrayed as an anti-hero
so it really seems like they're setting
people up that kong is the underdog
kong is gonna win in this one however i
don't think that's the case and i'm not
stating godzilla will win because of
physicality let's just completely
move all that out of the way i feel like
purely off of a business decision
off of just touhou being involved in
here because they don't have any more
plans
definitive ones for future godzilla
films after godzilla vs kong maybe
they've had some talks behind the scenes
but nothing that's been officially
reported
i don't think touhou working with
legendary pitchers
would let the godzilla lose
in this movie especially after the
backlash
that king kong vs godzilla received for
letting kong win
if i'm not mistaken there was a rumor
going around i don't know if this is a
definitive
but rko pitchers owned uh king kong at
the time when king kong vs godzilla came
out and archaic pitchers wasn't cool
with letting king kong lose in that
movie so i kind of feel like there's a
fliparoo here
now that this is an american-made film
you know with touhou
financing this picture i just don't
think touhou is gonna let
their main guy i don't think they're
gonna let him lose in this movie and
also from a business standpoint when it
comes to pulling characters from the
rogues gallery i mean
remember how excited people were here
like oh man they're bringing mothra in
for king of the monsters they're
bringing
king ghidorah in for king of the
monsters
exactly the fact that we're getting
mecha godzilla yeah
and godzilla versus kong is pumping
people up the rogues gallery for
a continuing franchise leans more in
godzilla's favor
versus kong's road gallery which is a
little more mysterious right now not
that i'm saying that they can't pull
that off that they can't continue kong
and then
bring out some new villains into new
characters and stuff in a day and age
where we
lean so much off of existing ip and
nostalgia
godzilla's the one with the franchise
they have toho finance in this
i don't think touhou would be cool with
letting godzilla lose and i think if
legendary wants to continue making
godzilla movies
they're gonna want to let godzilla win
that's purely where i'm coming from
i think godzilla will win just because
of business
just because of financial decision made
their people hashed it out before the
fight even begins it's a lot like boxing
i don't think anyone will die
but i think whoever loses it's gonna be
kong
only because of that yeah and then from
there you can set up some other thing
with kong where he goes off and you know
is the king of the hollow earth or
something like that and godzilla sort of
remains at the surface
our protector and balance or of the
world
health and ecology cycle there's a lot
of plot theories that have gone around
as to why kong would win i mean hey the
trailer sets you up that kong's the
underdog he should win
kong is not crowned king kong yet so if
he were to beat godzilla then he would
become officially king kong
like those all sound good those all
sound like very reasonable outcomes and
and
story purposes why let's face it movies
like this
it's all about that money baby it all
comes down to it and the president of
toho has been apparently
involved in person at meetings you know
about this movie you know signing off on
the treatment of the character the
spiritual handling of the character the
story etc and is reportedly quite happy
with it it seems to me that yeah
especially on the heels of the outcome
last time now would probably be the time
especially being that this is the fourth
installment of a franchise that king
kong has only been the star of one of
seems kind of more appropriate in the
overall
scope of what they've built here and i
mean touhou has also been pretty open
about yeah we're kind of waiting to see
what happens with godzilla versus kong
because we really like what we're
building
on the american side but we might want
to do our own thing in japan maybe we'll
combine
those two it seems like a lot of the
future rests down godzilla
avenue yeah in one way shape or form
yeah so that's just it guys it comes
down to business
working with touhou yeah like they
already upset the godzilla fans by
letting godzilla lose in the first one
would they really let them do that
again i'm open to whoever wins at this
point at this point i'm really open to
it same time
i feel like i got pretty solid reasons
as to why
we'll lose i'm just hoping for a good
fight man that's what i just want to
have
i just want to be an entertaining maybe
a little surprised yeah yeah i think
it's gonna be entertaining exciting
it'll be a good time all right guys well
who do you think will win
leave your thoughts down below here's
see what you all have to say what are
your theories of how the movie will end
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button last but not least
jm valente john i think you're great at
these jay
you know who you remind me of you remind
me of john goodman's character
in kong skull island i imagine there's
all kinds of crazy conspiracies
and theories that you have that are
based on so much
knowledge life experience and science
but you always come off a little bit
kooky well guess what i
believe you and i think that wherever
you are in the world right now
you're on the verge of some kind of
crazy discovery that's gonna blow the
doors
off the world man you're gonna find the
hollow earth and then you're gonna send
us a rambling message from in there
where we're like
cool i think i hope he's doing all right
he's at least able to type this so
i assume he's okay at least in his
physical bodies i hope you're having a
nice
2021 wherever you happen to be if you
even receive this message and uh
stay sexy be well
wow